on the hill today for the giants will be
the right-handed veteran johnny quido
quito 35 years of age in his 14th year
at the big league level this is what
he's done this year in seven starts
three and one with a 381 era
31 strikeouts against six walks you're
going to see a low to mid 90s fastball
best velocity will always be in two
strike situations he's a great change up
he'll cut the ball he also has a
curveball
and here's keon wong
this is hit up the middle crawford's got
it he's going to step on the bag for one
to throw to first not in time for
crawford the ability to get the lead
runner just under the glove of
johnny cueto and
just one of those defensive sets where
it's going to be tough to make a double
play look if they don't put the
defensive set there they probably don't
get the ball keon wong is at first base
and here is anthony rendon there's a
throw to first and he oh he's out and
not yeah they got him
kind of a double call but the last one
is the one that counts now johnny cueto
has the best move
of any right hander in this giant staff
and you might even say any left-hander
as well just great quick feet sets up
the move and look at the strike
and all lamont wade has to do is drop
and slap and in the end kian wong
had none chance toast dylan bundy now
bundy last couple of outings have been
very tough as a matter of fact last
three have been a big time challenge
though a couple of times he's pitched
against the astros this year he's been
dynamic he has had positive starts this
year he needs one today to lamont wade
jr
that's a change-up that's rolled to the
right side
flipped to the athletic bundy covering
walsh to bundy buster posey
got him over the outside corner
that is a breaking ball posey goes down
on strikes seventh start of the year for
anthony bamboo the runners on first and
third
anthony rolls it to the right side they
get one crawford can't get it out of his
glove and the halos take advantage they
strike first with a one to nothing lead
boy a break there you thought off the
back because it was hit pretty hard by
bembam there's a chance at a double play
ball crawford one of the best shortstops
for a lot of years
unable to get the baseball out of the
glove ward gets it to him quickly just a
bobble and a run scores and you got the
pitcher coming up and dylan bundy that
was a really important play it's a
little bit of a high throw no slide by
rojas forced a high throw they play
rendon to pull on the infield random get
well out into triples alley
yostremski's got a beat on it and he
runs it down not the spot to hit it in
this park well this is not anthony
rendon's first game
at oracle park he knows what triples
alley can do to a good at bat
teams cheat over is exactly what
yastripsky did i mean he was
cheating over about eight steps from
straightaway right field towards the gap
in right center and in the end it's just
an easy play it's so
such a fun play for us
one and two here's the pitch
got him challenged 94 for cueto's first
strikeout here's rojas got him there's
some anger behind that fastball elevate
just a simple thing is just changing
sight lines goes right up across the top
of the strike zone against rojas ben
boom reached on a fielder's choice
got him finally got him to chase after
that
up and of the three that he saw in that
sequence that was probably the worst the
one that was farthest away from the
strike zone started out there two c
movement let the tail kind of run away
and get the swing through see ya bundy
here's the pitch swung on and missed
strike three got him to change up so
cueto hits the first battery of the
inning and then strikes out three in a
row the angels don't score longoria and
see if you can get something that you
can hit hard somewhere
high drive left field it is out of here
and the giants take the lead stay hot
evan longoria that was a sweet swing
right there home run number nine on the
year
and that is just a thing of beauty 91
dropping middle in just above the knee
and longoria
just makes it look so easy
gets it a third of the way up in the
bleachers that's the freddie couple
swing we talk about yeah start slow
finish slow but in between the duggar
left-handed hitter the one-two pitch
duggar knew it five strikeouts for bundy
he's pitched well
had a change up and then he followed it
right where the fastball they set a wide
target hits the glove rough
strike two cueto had a sacrifice but his
first time giants leading two to one
bundy's got this one lunging to his
right and reaching over his head to
backhand it bundy and he throws cueto
out at first
two out and lamont way junior's gonna
hit with two outs and he'll take his
time to give johnny cueto a chance to
get back into the dugout wait a ground
ball and a strikeout
high and deep down the line
it is
out of here and that's his first how
about that it's his third career first
one as a giant and that's one he'll
remember for a long time they set an
outside target a miss middle end just
above the thigh and wade says that's
where i like him and three and two
very high
and dave
and out of here mauricio dubois
makes it a four to one ball game he can
never hide a smile that's for sure no he
cannot well if you replace evan longoria
the deal is you have to hit like him and
he gets a high hanging breaking ball
from dylan bundy and takes on left
center
there's the hang and
boom there's the bang wilmer flores now
he's ready
here comes solano and the giants are
going to get an easy one and i think
that's a cross up that thing took off
too set an outside target and that just
kept sweeping that was not a breaking
ball that ball just takes off that's
that could be a pass ball
remember the catcher i mean he really
got eaten up by that thing that's big
movement every once in a while it'll
happen
hit pitchers can't even explain how it
happens now five to one giants leading
here's the one-two pitch
right center field
and nobody is there
duggar scores
flores gets to jog easily into second
base
with a double nice and bad
so the line change works the line change
works i bring in a lefty
and you take your lefty out of the game
you put your righty in and that's what
you do you go inside out you find a gap
in right center
hit it completely away from the angels
defense they had no chance at it
tommy at third two down in the ninth
praying to the count to ben boone and
the pitch
got him and that's the ball game and the
giants win their fourth in a row as they
take game one of this series from the
angels the final score the giants six
the angels won